هذه مسابقة عالمية بالنسبة لك إذا كان
الأمريكيون العاديون لا يزالون يفقدون
حياتهم وما زلنا نشهد المزيد من
الحالات كل يوم ، فهم يفقدون
حياتهم في كل مكان في العالم
وربما هذا سؤال يجب أن تطرحه على
الصين
لا تسألني  الصين هذا السؤال
حسنًا عندما تطرح عليهم هذا السؤال ،
قد تحصل على إجابة غير معتادة يا سيدي ،
لماذا تقول ذلك لي على وجه التحديد
أنا أخبرك أنني لا أقول إنه
دمية على وجه التحديد ، لكن لا بأس من أي شخص
آخر ، يرجى المضي قدمًا في الخلف  مكان
لا ، لا بأس ، لدي سؤالان بعد ذلك
، لا يمكنني معرفة ما كان يدور
في رأس الرئيس أو إذا كان يعلم أن
عرقية مراسلي CBS عندما
أخبرها أن تذهب للتحدث إلى الصين أو تتصل بالصين
ولكن ما نعرفه هو أنه لديه
تاريخ موثق جيدًا من إهانة
المراسلين والتعليقات المهينة بشكل خاص للمراسلات
، لذا
فقط لتذكير مشاهدينا لدينا
مونتاج لبعض ملاحظاته القبيحة ، لذا استمع إلى
هذا ، فأنت تريد تضمين
الكونغرس Blac  k المؤتمر
العام والكونغرس جيدًا ، أود أن أخبرك
بما تريد إعداد الاجتماع ،
هل تريد إعداد الاجتماع ، لا هل
هم أصدقاء لك
[موسيقى]
يا له من سؤال غبي هذا سؤال غبي ولكني شاهدته  أنت كثيرًا
تسأل الكثير من الأسئلة الغبية
لماذا لا تتصرف بإيجابية أكثر قليلاً ،
إنها تحاول دائمًا طرح سؤالي لك
كيف حصلت عليك وأنت تعرف
سبب عدم ثقة أحد في وسائل الإعلام
بعد الآن شايي كيف يتم ذلك  ذاهب إلى
لم أسمعني لهذا السبب كنت
تعمل في صحيفة التايمز والآن أنت تعمل لدى
شخص آخر ، اسمح لي أن أقول لك
شيئًا لطيفًا لا تفاجئ
السؤال الصحيح لا يهدد ب
يجب أن نسمح للناس  اعلم أنك
كنت المراسل الذي كان يشير إليه
في منتصف ذلك المونتاج حيث
قال شيئًا عن سؤال غبي ،
فما رأيك عندما
رأيت هذا التبادل بالأمس نعم أليسون
أعني أنه جزء من نمط وهو
حقًا  نمط واضح كان goi
نانوغرام لسنوات حتى الآن تعرف Kaitlynn
أنها كانت في تلك الأنواع من
التفاعلات مع الرئيس قبل
أن يبدو أنه لا يتسامح مع
الأسئلة الصعبة خاصة من
النساء ومن ثم تعلم أنني أعتقد أن ما
حدث بالأمس في حديقة الورود
مع نحن gia  كنت أعتقد حقًا أنه
مزعج لكثير من الناس لأننا
جو صحفية صينية أمريكية
لكنها تعمل لصالح CBS News
[موسيقى]